المحليات الصناعيه التي نلجا اليها عاده
كبديل السكر يبدو انها اخطر منه فدراسه
طبيه حديثه توصلت لانه يمكن ان تزيد من
خطر الاصابه بالنوبات القلبيه والسكتات
الدماغيه نتائج الدراسه التي نشرت بدوريه
من المحليات المضافه الى الاطعمه المصنعه
قد تزيد من خطر الاصابه بجلطات الدم وجد
الباحثون للاشخاص الذين لديهم في دمائهم
كميات كبيره من الاثريتول هو سكر صناعي
ويستخدم كمحلل صناعي في اكثر من 50 دوله
كانوا اكثر عرضه للاصابه بنوبه قلبيه او
سكته دماغيه بمقدار الضعف مقارنه بمن كانت
لديهم كميات اقل
المحليات الصناعيه تزيد مخاطر الاصابه
بالسكته الدماغيه ونوبات القلب الى اي مدى
هذا دقيق خلينا نقول مبدئيا واحد اي
محليات بناخذها زياده عن الحد تتحول الى
دهون تؤثر الى سلبا على صحه الجسم وقد
تؤدي الى انسداد الشرايين فيما بعد هاي
واحد اثنين كل المحليات عشان نكون لسه كان
في انه ايش بدنا ناكل كل المحليات
فيما اذا استهلكت بالكميات المعقوله
والمدروسه حسب الاحتياج يعني انه ما تزيد
عن الحد لانه كل شيء يزيد عن الحد ينقلب
للضد وبالتالي اذا انا اخذتها في ضمن اطار
المعقول وهذا المعقول كيف انت بدك تنتبهي
انه وين موجوده موجوده في تشونج موجوده في
المخبوزات موجوده في المحل موجوده في
الفيتامين بعض الفيتامينات على فكره
موجوده في كثير من
الاغذيه اللي بتنعمل على اساس تكون
لوكالوري او
دكتوره وفاء بهاي الحاله لما نقول مثلا عن
شغله شوجر فري هاي صارت كذبه كبيره لا لا
ابدا ابدا هلا
لانه في بعض
كثير عم يلخبط
ممكن يكون فيها فعل فانت بدك تقرئي نو
قاعده
بشكركم لانه وجودي معكم وضح هاي النقطه
على الاقل الناس حتصير تقرا انه
ما فيها سكر ما فيها دهون كثير من الناس
بيروحوا للاشياء اللي فيها محليات او شقر
او مضاف اليه شقر وبياخدوا كميات كثير
كبيره اولا بتسبب اسهال قد تؤثر لتليف في
الكبد قد تؤدي الى مواد اخرى على الرغم
خليني اقول معلومه كثير واضحه عشان بس ما
يكون سوء فهم كل المحليات امنه استخدامها
اذا تم استخدامها في حدود المعقول شو
الكميه المسموحه يسلم هالتم اولا على حسب
في حسب النوع يعني مثلا خلينا نقول في
انواع بتعطيكي غرام بيعطيك اربع كالوريس
وبالتالي تحسب على حسب سعرات الحراريه
بحيث انها ما تزيد تعطيك الصفر سعرات
حراريه ولكن المسموح فيها اذا زاد يعني
مثلا خلينا نقول نفس الارستول اللي محطوط
في هو سكر هو كربوهيدرات ومن سكريات
الكحوليه اللي موجوده صفر كانوليز ما فيها
سعر ولكن 75 جرام لكل كيلو جرام بالوزن
جرام فعلى حسب وزن اذا زاد عن ذلك يتخزن
على هيئه الدهون يؤدي الى مشاكل اخرى
[موسيقى]